[Musique]
tu es prêt pour ça Je n'ai jamais été prêt
pour quoi que ce soit de toute ma vie tu sais que je
t'aime quoi qu'il arrive
j'étais dans ta tête je
me disais tout le temps
[Musique]
il y a quelque chose que je dois te dire que nous
sommes  boire à une nouvelle vie Tish va avoir des
drôles bébé j'espère que c'est un garçon viens
par ici fille tu es une bonne fille
et je suis fier de toi ne l'
oublie jamais
et qui sera responsable de ce
bébé le père et  la mère quand je
te tiens dans mes bras j'ai tout mon bébé dans
mes bras je trouverai un moyen cet enfant est
né du péché un enfant c'est ton petit-enfant
quelle différence cela fait-il comment il arrive
ici
euh inclinez la tête
[Musique]
nous avons connu la vie du père de Bonnie
il est sur le point de payer pour quelque chose qu'il
n'a pas fait
ce sont des enfants et nous devons les
libérer
rappelez-vous amoureux ce qui vous a amené ici
[Musique]
et si vous faites confiance au-dessus de jusqu'ici
juste  tout le chemin rappelez-vous juste être sur
certains
vous